well that was exciting yeah right again
no no answers uh not even a clues it
turns out you can get reflection on yeah
go on there we go um this is the return
I was just kind of waiting for something
to happen right it's like all just so
much feelings and emotions and you know
no action or oh we get is that giant
hand from super smash brothers I was
waiting for it to go ha ha ha ha ha ha
um know what you're really fucking thing
I'm sorry just all right yeah prefer a
two party then oh there's more no that's
the end of the show just up there Oh see
I just thought it was a bit of a letdown
ending but uh yeah it's very Sopranos
that way just cuts to black that's it um
no this is uh you know the funny thing
is um we were talking about like the big
battles and stuff like that and we sort
of have this really intimidating thing
come down we get a lot of politician I'm
always scared when fingers are pointed
at me uh and comes down and pretty much
like it goes very walking dead to me
like with the talent evacuating it's
genuinely uncomfortable you feel this
threat throughout the whole thing
haven't been it and they go up to it
really it's just that dread feeling that
you go up against something and it's
like you don't even have a chance and it
doesn't even really sort of play around
with it's like no you would you only
didn't have a chance and you lost they
had a little bit more chance with
Stephen there yeah it's just sand again
um but uh yeah uh no I don't disagree
and obviously I mean they explained more
how much to even really is pros even you
must be that voice for these useless
town folk oh that's so friggin bright ok
sorry just get to his down a touch are
you do Josie experts in mic OCD sorry um
that looks a little better or maybe not
hey we know watch the sun's gonna go
down what are you know what we got
automat
like this shit nowhere now I'm just
gonna turn up a little brighter
I'm totally distracting from this
episode sorry uh also uh lapis a -
Lepidus is that what she said they were
coming she warned them um but uh it
looks like she's in cahoots with them
well and again I mean they sort of
clarify what we knew we just did know
that I know like double triple quadruple
Quint sextuplet double-crossed one thing
is obvious yeah she's probably gonna
turn around and be like a big shiny he's
probably forced and yeah she's obviously
very for luggage old if you will um but
uh yeah you have this great big
intimidating force I don't know that's
yellow diamond or yellow diamond it's
something else cuz she says yellow
diamond has to see this it's like does
she is it like the rock or the polder if
though is it like the whole series
nothing hearts and purple horseshoes
this is one rissalah insurance
commercial ever I know I'm like wow
Lucky Charms oh no diamonds attack eat
these Lucky Charms
um you know she splits a garden in half
uh you know we're kind of mines me the
characters are kind of right to be the
bad guy from IB Incredibles you caught
me monologue yeah well I guess she
legitimately doesn't care until she sees
what Stephen is and then she becomes
introspective so much more um god I
still love peridot designed to the way
she can just take a part in the fingers
an edge every time I see them like yeah
that's such a cool design Oh they killed
Garmin you bastard well they split her
in half
Vermeer we saw that with Pearl Channel
like you know you can get this is scary
but and what a great part to stop I mean
like I said it's not even like it's not
even that big a battle it's just like a
No
piss off you know I mean it's just like
a bitch-slap and they're down I mean I
just another how much did like was
Steven a rut I feel like when his dad
was explaining things that Steven should
have somehow known some of this but the
problem is the show is in such small
snippets you kind of carry such a lot
yeah I kind of forget as like did Steven
know
this shit or like cuz for me as an
audience member I'm like yeah this was
like kind of Redux of like well we
didn't know whether while we knew was
thousands almost like we're grown-ass
adults watching a curtain ever ride
bunch of loser say no I I mean that was
fine to get the recap but it was more I
didn't mind the recap it was more like
I'm like didn't Steven know this but
maybe he didn't cuz yeah it is kind of
hard remembering um or it just didn't
Steven kind of figure it out or whatever
um but but we do get a little bit more
info that was mostly rose that sort of
cut them away from you know sort of the
gems doing these bad things and they
just pretty much take over whatever they
come across um II do anime yeah cuz
pearl like those one of the ones were
pearls said she would follow rose to the
ends of the air I mean if you're going
to follow somebody that means it was
their idea hence you are following them
that I guess so
oh so but yeah there are no useful
information delivered well but I've
never wasted nobody got Asia I I thought
it was fine I just it does sort of show
me you need the recap in case you
haven't been watching the show from the
beginning yeah well me that's what this
is yeah a thousand years things but
you're right I guess sort of thoughts
team will figure that out too but again
just sort of that resentment that they
follow her they're like okay we're with
you let's go and then she sort of finds
a guy and becomes you know becomes this
child or whatever and again it's like
okay it's your life it's like yeah we
kind of we kind of gave up everything
here you know to kind of follow you and
now you're doing this and we're gonna
sort of be like almost raising you and
stuff so it's not that it's bad but you
can kind of see where they would feel
like I said kind this hostility both
kind of towards her or towards
themselves or whatever just these unfit
out feelings uh you know life's Canon
one of the greatest weapons to
completely fail it was really cool she
let go right now there was all that
build-up it's like no because like oh I
thought that was going to be more
impressive well and I you know there's
something we see whatever joint hands in
movies and stuff our shows what I mean
that's nothing that new but just the
pointing I thought that was very
intimidating we
want you um and yeah we can see this new
villain come out and it's obviously very
intimidating
um and takes them out very easily but is
intrigued with you know rose being
whatever Steven now um and yeah we we
don't know what happened the next one's
called jailbreak so I'm assuming it's
then breaking out of prison and no it's
actually about them going to prison it's
ironic twist well they have to go to
prison to break out of into but why
don't you just play the next book maybe
I will um but yeah I think there's any
other one of them what happened was the
one last thing I'll bring up oh my god I
love how they I love puppies
we're sitting here and it's on pause
right over here I want to know what
happened the last thing I'll say is that
I love how in such a short time span
adventure time does this too and I'm so
impressed by it that they can like the
town is leaving they're all getting out
there and stuff and within I mean these
are only eleven minutes and you feel
like wow this is really big what's going
on right now even though it's just the
town leaving and said it's like you get
it and it's all really great that's
wonderful you would be even more amazing
if I found out what happens after that
eleven minutes you know I'm just gonna
stall here I'm gonna hold government
hostage while I just read all this stuff
I have my lunch set and everything and
I'm going to wash it down I'm going to
stall yeah you get to put on